a un día de que expire el cese el fuego
actual el líder del ejército sudanés
abdel fatal alburán anunció una
aprobación inicial para extender La
tregua por 72 horas más
Aunque el actual cc que está vigente
desde el pasado 24 de abril no ha sido
completamente respetado Mientras tanto
los civiles luchan por sobrevivir
detengan la guerra somos civiles
pacíficos que simplemente buscan ganarse
la vida y les pedimos a los que están en
el poder que sientan compasión por
nosotros ustedes no están en el poder
para siempre hagan algo ahora que
beneficie el futuro el líder del
ejército también dijo que está dispuesto
a enviar un representante a negociar con
el grupo y un acuerdo total podría estar
lejano el Ministerio del interior de
ciudadana acusó a las FARC de haber
irrumpido en seis cárceles del país para
liberar al ex dictador Omar al bashir y
a decenas de sus aliados el mandatario
fue derrocado en 2019 tras 30 años en el
poder las calles de jartum la capital se
casi desiertas y se empieza a reportar
escasez de alimentos gas y medicamentos
la bms ha advertido que además de las
muertes por combates esperan mucho más
debido a brotes de enfermedad falta de
acceso a alimentos y agua potable por lo
que su director general ofreció ayuda
la OMS tiene existencias de medicamentos
esenciales bolsas de sangre suministros
de cirugía y atención traumatológica en
espera de entrega pero necesitamos un
acceso seguro para hacer eso como
siempre la mejor medicina es la paz
entre tanto los gobiernos de distintos
países continúan evacuando a sus
ciudadanos y diplomáticos del país
africano en conflicto